Caos y destrucción una fuerte jornada de
lluvias recorta afecto del Norte del
estado de Sao Paulo en Brasil durante el
fin de semana de carnaval provocando
inundaciones y deslizamientos de tierra
el gobernador de Sao Paulo decreto del
estado de calamidad pública por 180 días
en las cinco ciudades más afectadas
gobernador tarsicio de freitas decretó
estado de calamidad Pública para las
ciudades de uvatuba Sao Sebastián y la
vela caraguatatuba y bertihoga
impactadas por las intensas lluvias que
azotan la región las lluvias acumularon
unos 600 milímetros superando el nivel
que se esperaba para todo el mes de
febrero mientras que cientos de personas
se vieron obligadas a evacuar sus
hogares la policía militarizada dispuso
de varias aeronaves para el rescate de
víctimas y la movilización de ayuda
humanitaria para Los afectados las
labores en el puerto de Santos el más
grande de América Latina fueron
detenidas en medio de las ráfagas de
viento que lograron marcar hasta 55
kilómetros por hora el gobernador de Sao
Paulo tarcizo de freitas quien sobrevoló
la zona afectada anunció el desembolso
de 7 millones de reales alrededor de
unos 1.5 millones de dólares para las
tareas de rescate y reconstrucción la
liberación de recursos se realiza como
una apertura de crédito complementario
al presupuesto fiscal en la secretaría
de relaciones gubernamentales e
institucionales el decreto que determina
la liberación de recursos entra en vigor
de inmediato según reportó el Instituto
Nacional de meteorología las lluvias
continuarán en la zona costera del
Estado lo que podría agravar la
situación